[Música]
el secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos Anthony blinken viajar el domingo
a China en un encuentro considerado
clave para mantener abierta la
comunicación entre ambas naciones en un
momento de alta tensión la visita estaba
planeada para febrero pero fue
suspendida por el sobrevuelo de un
presunto globo espía chino por el
espacio aéreo estadounidense
en Guatemala el periodista José Rubén
Zamora uno de los principales críticos
del gobierno de Alejandro yamatei fue
condenado este miércoles a seis años de
prisión por lavado de dinero en un
proceso señalado de Star plagado de
irregularidades tenemos análisis
El Congreso de El Salvador aprobó la
reducción del número de municipios que
pasará de 262 a 44 a partir de mayo de
2024 según el presidente de la asamblea
la reducción supone un ahorro de 250
millones de dólares anuales pero para la
oposición es una táctica del gobierno de
bukele para mantener el control
territorial
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos porque por primera vez en
cinco años un secretario de estado
viajará a China Anthony blinquen llegará
este domingo a Beijing y la Casa Blanca
anunció que el objetivo es mantener
abierta la comunicación entre ambos
países una situación difícil por las
relaciones que se han deteriorado ante
la posibilidad de un enfrentamiento por
Taiwán y la guerra comercial Además este
viaje estaba previsto para febrero pero
fue suspendido tras el episodio del
presunto globo espía chino que sobrevoló
espacio aéreo estadounidense esto Dijo
el departamento de estado la visita del
secretario se basa en una serie de
compromisos posteriores a la
conversación entre el presidente biden y
el presidente Sheen Valley donde
acordaron mantener los canales abiertos
para como mínimo evitar errores de
cálculo y sigue el trabajo que hemos
realizado desde el comienzo de esta
administración para fortalecer la
capacidad de sonidos para superar a
China incluidas inversiones históricas
en el país y la alineación con aliados y
socios en el extranjero siguen sumándose
nombres a la Baraja de precandidatos que
buscan la nominación republicana la
presidencia de Estados Unidos El último
en inscribir su aspiración fue el
alcalde de Miami Francis Suárez este
político de 45 años Fue comisionado en
el ayuntamiento de la ciudad entre 2009
y 2017 y se convierte así hasta el
momento en el único precandidato
republicano de ascendencia Latina Suárez
se une a la disputa por la nominación
que incluye al gobernador de Florida ron
de Sánchez El ex vicepresidente Mike
pence y el expresidente Donald Trump
entre otros
vamos a Guatemala el periodista José
Rubén Zamora fundador del medio del
periódico fue condenado a seis años de
prisión por lavado de dinero el caso ha
sido señalado de tener motivaciones
políticas ya que el medio público
múltiples investigaciones sobre
corrupción en el gobierno de Alejandro
yamatei de hecho forzaron a que el
periódico cerrara y otros ocho
periodistas están investigados
previamente conversamos con Evelyn Blanc
directora y fundadora del centro civitas
Guatemala y periodista del colectivo no
nos callarán que nos dijo Cuál ha sido
la importancia de José Rubén Zamora a
nivel periodístico
el periódico en realidad no ha sido solo
crítico de Alejandro yamate y el
periódico ha sido crítico de todos los
gobiernos en realidad ha sido un medio
que ha aportado muchísimo muchísima
información con base en en investigación
Y en este sentido ha sido considerado un
medio muy relevante en Guatemala en
términos de hacer comprender a la
ciudadanía el grado de corrupción que ha
asistido a todos estos gobiernos lo
sucedido al Señor Zamora se enmarca
además en una estrategia de
criminalización que es generalizada que
lo que pretende silenciar a la a la
prensa para que prosiga su camino Este
modelo autoritario que se está
implantando en el país
El Salvador reducirá drásticamente la
cantidad de municipios la asamblea
dominada por partidos afines al
presidente nayib bukele aprobó el
proyecto de ley que obliga a pasar de
262 municipios a 44 la medida aplicará
desde 2024 pero desde ya los críticos
señalan que beneficiará electoralmente a
bukele quien también logró reducir los
escaños del legislativo Alba Santana
tiene la historia
lo prometió ya ha pasado a la acción
tras la aprobación de la asamblea el
gobierno de nayib bukele promulgó una
ley este miércoles
queda aprobada la ley en términos
generales
la ley especial de reestructuración
municipal que reducirá los 262
municipios del país a tan solo 44 un
movimiento impulsado por bukele y su
partido nuevas ideas bajo el argumento
de reducir los gastos estatales y
combatir la corrupción
he firmado y autorizado que se convierta
en ley la total reorganización de la
división político administrativa de El
Salvador historia no obstante la
oposición de este movimiento como un
nuevo abuso de poder del mandatario y lo
acusa de querer sacar a crédito
electoral centralizar El Poder y quitar
autonomía a los municipios qué obtiene
la el gobierno en beneficio digamos o
por qué quiere hacer esto advertimos que
los los centros las concentraciones de
población se están produciendo de una
manera que pueda provocarle mayores
réditos electorales al gobierno durante
su discurso de cuatro años de gobierno
bukele prometió una reducción del estado
por lo que hace apenas una semana redujo
el número de diputados de 84 a 60 tras
su aprobación la nueva ley se aplicará a
partir de mayo de 2024 cuando muchos
municipios pasarán a ser distritos
tras su reunión en Santiago el
presidente de Chile Gabriel boric y la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
fonder leían anunciaron la concesión de
un fondo europeo de unos 243 millones de
dólares para promover el desarrollo de
la Industria Del hidrógeno verde
recordó que el bloque es el cuarto socio
comercial y principal inversor de chile
para 2030 estará importando 10 millones
de toneladas por año
se espera que la demanda de litio crezca
significativamente en ambos continentes
porque estamos trabajando Para
descarbonizar nuestras economías y aquí
las materias primas críticas juegan un
papel importante no hay aerogenerador
sin litio por ejemplo no hay baterías y
materias primas críticas es por eso que
hemos acordado que queremos trabajar en
una asociación estratégica sobre
materias primas sostenibles y toda la
cadena de valor
la fundación cluny para la justicia ha
apelado al principio de jurisdicción
universal para tratar de que un tribunal
argentino investigue y sancione a las
fuerzas de seguridad de Venezuela por lo
que ha denunciado como crímenes de lesa
humanidad que no constituyen casos
aislados sino una política de estado
humanizada nos cuenta los antecedentes
en los que se basa esta demanda
una esperanza de Justicia una
organización de defensa de Derechos
Humanos la fundación cluny para la
justicia denunció a las fuerzas de
seguridad de Venezuela ante un tribunal
argentino la fundación invoca el
principio de jurisdicción universal y la
falta de garantías para que presuntos
crímenes de lesa humanidad sean
investigados y procesados en Venezuela
no estamos hablando de casos aislados o
no se tratan de violaciones derechos
humanos aisladas sino que hay una
creemos que una política de estado en
Venezuela hay una sistematicidad donde
vemos que no es solo una persona de
cometer los delitos sino que hay una
cadena de Mando donde se dan órdenes el
esfuerzo de la fundación creada por la
abogada de Derechos Humanos a Mark cluny
recibió el apoyo de amnistía
internacional
las víctimas que hoy han denunciado
crímenes de lesa humanidad han confiado
en Argentina sus esperanzas de Justicia
los tribunales argentinos tienen
jurisdicción constitucional sobre estos
crímenes no por el lugar donde fueron
cometidos o por quién sino porque dañan
a la humanidad en su conjunto Esperamos
que la justicia Argentina esté a la
altura del desafío y mantenga su
tradición histórica de juzgar y
sancionar a los responsables de estos
crímenes a todos los niveles y es que
Argentina ya ha aplicado con
anterioridad el principio de
jurisdicción universal tribunales de ese
país se han pronunciado en torno a
crímenes el régimen franquista en España
e investigan el genocidio contra la
etnia rojilla en miamar la Corte Penal
Internacional abrió una causa formal
para investigar presuntos crímenes
contra la humanidad durante el gobierno
de Nicolás maduro y la misión de
determinación de hechos en la ONU
documentó ejecuciones extrajudiciales
desapariciones forzadas detenciones
arbitrarias tortura y tratos crueles
cometidos en Venezuela desde 2014
finalizamos en Perú porque estudiantes e
investigadores de la Universidad de San
Marcos encontraron una momia que tendría
unos tres mil años cerca de Lima
inicialmente encontraron restos de su
cabello y un cráneo en un empaque de
algodón esto durante la excavación
trabajos posteriores en el sitio
arqueológico de huaca la Florida
revelaron luego el resto de la momia
además fueron desenterrados cuellos de
botella maíz hojas de coca y semillas
los expertos creen que pudo ser parte de
una ofrenda
es todo por el momento en France 24
gracias por su sintonía
[Música]